hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Martin Heidegger is si what is
metaphysics contains some very difficult
but very rewarding portions and passages
and transitions one of those has to do
with this this ongoing discussion which
is centered in one part will show up a
little bit later about which really have
the fundamental priority the negation or
the not or the nothing and one way that
people have traditionally made sense of
this this nothing whatever the nothing
happens to be or not be is to think of
it as fundamentally dependent upon an
act of the the intellect an act of our
faculty of thought our highest faculty
that carries out all of this these
processes for us and Heidegger will ask
us this question during the part that
he's calling the elaboration of the
question do not the not negated Ness and
thereby negation to represent the higher
determination under which the nothing
Falls as a particular kind of negated
matter that is a fundamental question a
very important way of looking at things
and it's tied in with this formula that
he's going to come back to as the
nothing is or nothing is the complete
negation of the totality of beings and
so is this going to be the way that
we're going to look at it because if
that's the case then there really is a
priority first we have the intellect and
its workings and we have the positivity
of being and then we take that and we
strip things away from it we abstract we
negate and through that activity we
arrive at this blank featureless nothing
or could it be that things are actually
the other way which is what Heidegger
himself
is going to advocate and suggest to us
is the reality of our existence
so he's going to go on actually here we
go and tell us here we go
our negation and the not given only
because the nothing is given that hasn't
been decided at that point in the the
inquiry it has not even been raised
expressly as a question we assert this
is Heidegger that the nothing is more
original than the not and negation now
asserting is not the same thing as
demonstrating or providing a reasoning
for or an account for and that is what
he's going to do later on in the work
but he's telling us this is something
that we have all too often taken for
granted and not engaged and not examined
not gone to the root of so let's see how
we actually would get the nothing from
negation is is what he's telling us so
he goes on and he says we we should not
let ourselves be misled by the formal
impossibility of the question of the
nothing if we pose the question in spite
of this we must at least satisfy what
remains the basic demand for any
advancing of every question if the
nothing itself is to be questioned as we
have been questioning it then it must be
given beforehand we must be able to
encounter it and the question that is do
we encounter the nothing we certainly
talk about it it's there in our speech
is that just an inaccurate way of
talking on our part of carelessness that
a truly scientific attitude towards not
only language but beings would eliminate
and show us traces back ultimately to
this activity of negation that remains
to be seen
so it says where are we going to seek
the nothing where will we find in order
to find something must we already not
know in general it is there it says
indeed and first and for the most part
man can seek only when he's anticipated
to be
at hand of what he's looking for now
that nothing is what we're seeking is
there ultimately such a thing as a
search without that anticipation so he
says well whatever we do make of it we
do know that nothing if only as a word
we rattle off every day so what is it
well we begin with this definition the
complete negation of the totality of
beings and he says ok so what does this
mean for us how do we wrap our heads
around this definition this is actually
a good digression to make lots of people
love to give definitions and talk about
beginning from a definition Webster's
dictionary defines blah blah blah blah
blah that's only meaningful if the
definition allows us to actually wrap
our heads around or to encounter the
beings that are being defined in there
if it's a good definition if it's
something more than just you know a
bunch of words strung together or
somebody's proposed idea of what this is
many definitions are actually quite
garbage that's something to keep in mind
what about this definition is this going
to be valuable for us how do we
encounter a complete totality of beings
how do we encounter beings to begin with
that's worth dwelling on Heidegger is
not going to dwell on that much here
although he does in other places how do
we run it into the totality Heidegger
says that the totality of beings must be
given in advance to be able to fall
straight prey straight away to negation
in which the nothing itself would be
manifest how are we who are essentially
finite to make the whole of beings
totally penetrable in itself and also
for us he says well we can imagine we
can think the whole of beings in an idea
and then negate what we've imagined in
our thought we can sort of bring the the
totality of beings into the limited
space of our head and then put a big
knot sign through that or we can do the
sort of process
so saying not this not this not this not
this not this not this and then just put
dot dot dot ad infinitum after that
that's merely in thought that's carrying
things out by ways of ideas but does
that really negate the totality of being
no and he says in this way we do it say
in the formal concept that imagine
nothing but we never attain the nothing
itself we get something out of that we
don't get what we are looking for and he
says the nothing is nothing and if
nothing represents total
indistinguishability no distinction can
obtain between the imagined and the
proper nothing and even this proper
nothing if we engage in the time at the
proper nothing aren't we forgetting the
fact that nothing is not something it
can't be treated as of something it's no
being we haven't grasped the nothing yet
so he goes on and he says we you know
one way in which you're going to do this
is through mood and we'll talk about
that separately in a different video a
little bit later on in the section the
response to the question he's going to
tell us that it's really the opposite
way we've been wrong in thinking that
the nothing was radically dependent upon
the intellect and its operation of
negating instead its negation and the
not is going to be dependent upon and
arise from the nothing and there will be
a whole interesting complicated picture
here in heidecker's depiction of how
this takes place but we should mention
just a few things from this he tells us
that the knot does not originate through
negation rather negation is grounded in
the knot and the knot Springs from the
nihill ation of the nothing the nothing
of the nothing the way nothing does
whatever or the way nothing
exerts its attraction upon being and
then he says this is actually only one
way of neha laning of nothing and so
this means that nothing is the origin of
negation not vice-versa and this also
means this is a corollary for the
intellect he says if the power of the
intellect in the field of inquiry into
the nothing and into being is the
shattered then the destiny of the rain
of logic and philosophy is thereby
decided the idea of logic itself
disintegrates in the turbulence of a
more original questioning now if at this
point in hearing all of this discussion
you're a little bit lost you can always
go back and re-watch the video and of
course reread Heidegger's text but you
want to have some sort of feeling of
perhaps something like a vertigo or
confusion in hearing this it's difficult
to wrap our head even though we have a
word nothing me he'll I am you know
NIC's whatever else you want to say in
in languages we have this word but
grasping what the nothing actually is
turns out to be much more difficult but
opens the path to a grasp of what is
actually occurring in negation in the
use of the knot
you